porte de versailles c'est le salon de
l'habillement masculin ce monsieur
s'appelle jean marie il est mannequin et
présente une tunique de soirée en tissus
d'ameublement qui tour un battement de
cils et voilà la mode unisexe est lancé
regardez et écoutez
est ce que vous pourriez cette mode wynn
las les tuniques aussi alpiniste vous ne
trouvez pas qu'elle est un peu trop
féminine peu trop pas sexuée en eux non
pas du tout
ce que j'aime dans la nouvelle mode chez
les couleurs parce qu'autrefois les
hommes étaient toujours habillés en
marron en gris en bleu et maintenant
depuis quelques années on sort de ça et
je trouve que c'est très bien
oui mais on met des robes maintenant aux
hommes oui ça c'est pas encore descendus
dans la rue mais ce qui est descendue
déjà fait les couleurs et les matières
j'ai vu une grande tunique dorée avec
des bottes ou jetés pratiquement une
robe
oui alors
c'est joli c'est pour les deux pour la
fille et le garçon c'est vraiment très
jolie mettriez cela à quelle occasion
soirée une soirée
échauffement cocktails et les réactions
des gens dans la rue
est ce qu'ils lisent ils sont loin si m
trop lent à s'y mettent
les réactions sont trop quand son je
sais pas comment ils sont
un bag trouvez vous logique que l'homme
soit maintenant la copie conforme de la
femme non je crois pas qu'il soit la
copie conforme de la femme de façon je
crois que un couple peut au maximum se
ressemblent et s'habiller de la même
façon ça fait tout ça très joli mano met
un homme une femme et une femme quel que
soit l'avis qu'ils portent bien sûr
c'est pas l'habit qui fait le moine
c'est vrai qu'il est trouvé